this is a production of Cornell
University
so as Don mentioned I'm with the USDA I
am a research geneticist and I
specialize in abiotic stress physiology
and genetics in grape and grape is the
topic of today so grapes are one of the
leading horticultural fruits across the
globe and they're good to eat but their
end products are also really important
at lucrative juice raisins table grapes
and of course wine the thing that limits
grape vine is a narrow climatic band the
cultivated grape vine is a Mediterranean
adapted species and so if you look here
pictured on the map and try to get my
orientation with which slides to look at
if you look it is limited by a
temperature range between 10 and 20
degrees Celsius which captures the
Mediterranean area and then grape vine
producing areas you're probably familiar
with when it comes to wine California
Chile Argentina South Africa Australia
but we know that climate is changing and
there are new challenges emerging when
it comes to grape vine production so
pictured here in red are grape vine
regions that we currently have that were
expected to lose by 2050 the blue region
there those are in red the blue regions
are areas that we expect grape vine
production to be able to expand into
typically because of a warming climate
so with climate change we're expecting
four winters to become slightly warmer
but we're also expecting to have altered
weather patterns and so those altered
weather patterns do not remove the
threat of cold temperatures and
limitations to grapevine production
because I think we're all familiar with
if you were here in the last couple
years the polar vortex which is a very
common climatic event but one that we
just haven't seen in a while and so
pictured here is a heat map showing that
that polar vortexes believe this as two
years ago the temperature stove down
caused a lot of damage and grapevines
both here in New York and as well as in
the Midwest and it was just at a
conference where all of the producers
and all the winemakers are cold climate
grapevine producers so coming from
Scandinavia Canada
kind of thing we had a meteorologist to
give a talk about the polar vortex and
about climate change and he did a really
great job of explaining it and so I
thought I'd include that here just so
everybody has an understanding about how
that affects growing grapes in this
region growing grapes in areas where
climate is not a Mediterranean so the
traditional climate has a very cold pole
and very strong trade winds which keep
cold air during winter trapped at the
pole but as we experience warming and
preferential warming in the poles the
trade winds get weaker and then these
polar troughs become more regular as
cold air is able to slip out of the
poles and dip down into areas where we
were not traditionally experiencing such
cold snaps the flipside of that is
there's also warming Peaks that occur in
contrast for that so instead of a
generally warmer winter we're faced with
a more erratic winter where there are
going to be episodes of much warmer
temperature followed by episodes of much
colder temperature this wreaks a lot of
havoc on grapevines particularly when
you're pushing the temperature envelope
picture down here on the bottom is
another example of some of this weather
phenomenon as it affects horticultural
crops the bottom panel here is a picture
of the Midwest of America in April of
2006 and all right so this is like April
fourth this is April 22nd so you can see
the greening up that's the the trees and
article culture of crops all bursting
breaking bud in the previous are in this
year 2007 we experienced what was a
portal polar vortex although we
experienced it in the spring so you can
see how far advanced the green was when
you compare these two and then after the
polar vortex or the spring freeze you
can see how much of that foliage died
back in 2007 I don't even know the
billions of dollars that were lost in
horticultural crops because of this
event so these events are expected to
increase
but it's not always necessarily bad news
with climate change is also new
opportunities and I'm from the Upper
Peninsula of Michigan which is this
Peninsula here most people don't realize
that this is actually attached to
Michigan from this corner here I was
very surprised to see that grapevine
production is moving north in Michigan
so here along the coast of Michigan
there's a lot of wine trails a lot of
good hybrid and vanilla wines get made
here but now this little Peninsula here
there's a winery there and as you can
see by the suitability map there there
are some regions where they're
projecting that is more suitable for
wine I can tell you from the snowfall
levels that this is not going to be a
fun place to grow grapes but we have to
realize that there are challenges coming
with climate change there's also
opportunities and so is my job as a
geneticist with studying cold hardiness
in grapes to try to figure out the most
efficient way to get us through the
challenges and take advantage of the
opportunities we look at New York where
we're all familiar with picture on the
left is the grape growing regions of New
York and pictured on the right is the
hardiness map put up at the USDA you'll
notice that there's a correlation
between the dark purple areas on the
left with the green areas on the right
that's because temperature is the
primary limiting factor affecting
production agriculture production in
general but definitely great production
as I said the European grape vine is
adapted to Mediterranean climates so it
likes it nice and hot in the summer and
dry and mild and cool in the winter
because of that evolutionary history it
isn't adapted to deal with our winters
and particularly if you go further north
or west and north from here cannot deal
with the winters it is only cold hardy
to around negative 22 negative 25 C
which is negative 4 to negative 13 F and
I'll apologize right now not all of my
slides have C and F included but this is
the range we're looking at for
cultivated grapevine our most Hardy
cultivars in this region are like
Riesling and cap frog caps table they
can survive to these temperatures
so that's sort of the backdrop against
what my job is about and the goals of my
position are to understand and clarify
what the physiology is and what the
phenotype is of what what we say cold
hardiness so what does that mean I'm
also supposed to identify wild and
hybrid germ plasm that we can use to
advance grape I'm breeding to make new
varieties that are better adapted I'm
supposed to characterize the complex
architecture of those genetic
architecture of those traits and then
assess genetic mapping populations in
order to identify candidate genes that
play major roles so I have a number of
tools that I can use most importantly is
the USC a cold hardy grapevine germ
plasm which if you don't know we house
in Geneva it's about 1,300 different
grapevine genotypes those are all cold
hardy hybrids and wild grapevine species
that can survive our winters the other
half of the grapevine gene germplasm is
in davis california where all of the
cultivated varieties and cold sensitive
varieties are kept we have a pretty
amazing resource here and I definitely
stressed you should check it out
sometime I perform a lot of
physiological measurements of Grapevine
bud survival and phenology with both
field and lab based work and I'm trying
to employ next-generation DNA and RNA
sequencing technologies to move it
forward to identify the the complexities
behind these traits so I've already kind
of alluded to this but wild Vitus is
very important to grapevine improvement
I listed here just a sampling of
adaptive traits that we would really
like to have in cultivated varieties
that we can find in abundance and wild
species so we're talking about cold
resistance today but there's also
differences in soil adaptability rooting
pathogen resistance ripening differences
in vine architecture fruit flavors and
nutrition and then bubbler a bud burst
and d acclamation which I'll talk about
a little bit today too
these are the major wild species that we
have in the the cold hardy germplasm
here there
there are about 20 wild species in North
America and I'm picturing a few here and
introducing their names not expecting
you to know them all but just to give
you a sampling of the diversity that we
see when we look at wild species so
they're all sort of ringed around the
outside with Vitis vinifera Riesling in
the center lebra's Kison area esta
vollis ripe area Rupe estrus and volpina
are all major species we have in the
germplasm
but as Amy rensis is something from
eastern Asia that's used a lot in
Russian and Chinese great breeding
efforts and then like I mentioned
benefits in the center so they're
roughly 20 species in North America
there's something like 40 in Asia
they're adapted to different abiotic and
biotic stresses because of their
evolutionary path and where the group
where they have e adapted a pictured
here for different distribution maps for
a repast hrus lebra's scenario and ripe
area the bright green is a county level
distribution so you can see that they
they differ quite a bit in how prevalent
they are and what parts of our country
they cover as I mentioned cultivated
grape is called tender negative 22
negative 25 is its limit whereas cold
hardy wild species can reach negative 35
to negative 40 not much can go below
negative 40 and survive that's that's
the ultimate temperature for water so
now we're going to talk a little bit
about what do I mean by when I say cold
hardiness and cold yeah cool part enos
it's a very complex trait it depends on
which dish you are talking about for
this talk want to be speaking mostly
about garment buds but it also includes
phloem and xylem the lifeblood of the
plant as well as the cambium tissues is
all of these tissues have to deal with
freezing stress in our climate and they
may or may not use the same mechanisms
there are differences in the genes that
contribute to cold hardiness there's
differences in the physiology so whether
or not you are able to export water or
increase sugar concentration or modify
with cryo proteins all of this can be
different in these different tissues
and there's also mechanical differences
between the tissues and whether or not
they can prevent them the movement of
ice so you can have tissue barriers that
block ice propagation in the plant
there's also multiple versions of cold
hardiness depending on what season
you're talking about
so I'm picturing here on the bottom is a
time line going from fall through to
spring so if you get a very hard cold
frost early in the fall you can knock
the vine down and do damage before it's
ready for winter temperatures and thus
impede its ability to survive the rest
of the winter you can have massive cold
events during the middle of winter which
simply surpass the defenses of the plant
and kill the buds or if you have too
warm of a spring you can budburst early
and then you're subject to frost damage
depending on like I told you those
troughs and peaks and the weather can
really affect that but fall and spring
of but phenology when it comes down to
looking at the winter there's two major
groupings whether or not you have a mild
or cold winter so the intensity of the
winter and then the stability of the
winter whether or not you have very
punctuated swings in temperature or you
have sustained cold temperatures so
today we're going to talk about two of
all the complexity I introduced where I
talked about two portions of it
midwinter bud hardiness and endo
dormancy and bud burst so on the left is
the standard acclamation D acclamation
curve associated with plants going
through the winter in the fall they
react to changes in light and
temperature gaining cold hardiness and
moving down this u so they're
acclimating ahead of freezing
temperatures during the middle of winter
they're at their most hardy and then in
the spring as temperatures rise they D
acclimate at a rate that is faster than
they pack lamented you can assess
whether buds are surviving winter and
where they are on this curve by cutting
them and looking for damage so here on
the left is the compound bud of grape a
primary bud secondary and tertiary all
are green this bud survives well until
we cut it set up the center bud here has
a sustained damage in the primary bud
which is brown and the third but here is
completely dead so from a producer's
point of view you could get fruit off of
this plant you're going to get only
vegetative growth
this because the primary but is the
fruitful bud and you don't have any
growth and you're probably going to have
to replace your vine and the dormancy
and bud burst is then another topic we
will get into in a minute but basically
we assess the state of dormancy and the
ability to grow by taking buds from the
field and putting them into growing
conditions and that's what's pictured
here on the right the reason that I have
these two traits up here is because they
interact and overlap with one another so
throughout the acclamation and the
acclimation period you also have changes
in dormancy going on in the background
and so I'm trying to decide or trying to
figure out how interconnected these two
different traits are with one another
can we separate them and identify the
advanced germ plasm for each of those
traits mm-hmm
yeah it's the most sensitive and the
thought is that because the floral
tissue has more water but we're working
on that so here's my fifth-grade drawing
of what it's like to be a cell that
experiences cold snaps so we have a cell
on the left and though it's all the good
bits on the inside there you have a spy
of cold temperature and what from what
we know the cell tries to get rid of as
much free water as possible because free
water freezes so you get ice crystal
ages the ice crystallization between the
cells or perhaps just outside the plasma
membrane this sort of freezing is safe
and it occurs at around negative five
degrees Celsius it's called the hte or
high temperature exotherm cells that
have this ice form are under stress from
that ice but also from dehydration and
membrane fusion so there's a lot of
processes going on when when you have
ice formation as temperatures drop the
buds super cool so they suppress their
ability to freeze to a certain point at
some temperature and this varies
throughout the winter and by genotype
that intracellular water can no longer
be kept from freezing and it freezes
that signals the lethal event in the
cell so at that point the bud is dead
what exactly is happening when that ice
happens we don't quite know we're
working on that too but basically
there's a whole suite of tolerance and
avoidance methods that are postulated to
play a role in this differences in
membranes cryo protective of solutes
chaperones sugars suppression of ice
crystal form formation tissue barriers
all of these are thought to play a role
we can evaluate where the buds are on
that cold hardiness you using a method
called dt8 differential thermal analysis
and what we do is we take the bud here's
the dormant bud make an incision across
the bud cushion so you hear the
cross-section keeping this tissue intact
we put it into these trays stack the
trays in a programmable freezer then
slowly freeze the tissue as the
temperatures are decreasing when you hit
the hte that's safe freeze you get a
spike of water freezing here
this is a peak of heat and we recognize
that as a change in voltage across these
plates so that's the stay freezing and
then as you continue to drop in
temperature you hit the lethal events
and you see the buds dying here and
these little spikes so what we do is all
winter long we go out and collect tissue
put them in these chambers record these
Peaks average the peaks and figure out
what the 50% lethal point is and use
that as a method of measuring where the
buds are on that you so for the last
three years I've done this with seven
different species and about 33 different
genotypes and I'm not going to show you
all of the traces because it's way too
overwhelming but basically what it looks
like is done top right corner here this
is the minimum temperatures in the black
jagged line and here's Riesling and
Concord the lines the solid lines are
those LTE's the lethal temperatures and
then the dashed line is just a trend
line so you can see that Concord is
harder than Riesling this is something
we know very well so when we look across
these seven species and all these
genotypes from hardy to tender we
basically come up with the result right
Perry and a mere inches are the most
Hardy varieties then the rest of the
wild species are all within there we go
all within about a degree of each other
as well as scenario lab Rosco rebuff
repairs in volcana all of the wild
species are harder than the hybrid
varieties and those hybrids are harder
than vinifera so just keep that in your
mind mostly the two ends of this right
Perry and Emma insists are very Hardy
hybrid and vinifera are very tender we
look at 2012 2013 here I'm only showing
you right pairing Emmer insists and
hybrids you can see that we had this
black dash line as the freezing point
and these are minimum temperatures so
you can see we had a this is a pretty
mild winter temperatures go back and
forth across the freezing point several
times you can see that hybrid I'm your
ensign ripe area are all about equally
hardy but way more Hardy than
temperatures demand after this cold
event you can see a slight dip they're
responding to the cold temperatures then
there's a warming event Emmy rents this
response by D acclimating and throughout
the rest of the winter
you have this divergence so this isn't a
warm here this is a cold year 2013 2014
you can see that the lines are further
down they're more Hardy in this year and
now the blue line which is the hybrid
line is the least Hardy again you have
responses to temperature and D
acclamation all the way through the the
season here is last year which was also
a very cold ear but it was a very
different cold ear instead of having
lots of temperature swings throughout
the winter we had extremely cold
temperatures for two months straight so
you can see that the lines are much less
wavy and this cold event here pushed all
of the genotypes even the sensitive our
hybrid varieties far far harder than we
had seen previously so this is where the
type of winter really matters the last
year's winter that we had pushed hybrid
varieties way past what we would expect
them to normally be able to do simply
because the bright types of temperatures
occurred they were pushed down and kept
down they weren't allowed to die
acclimate so the type of winter
determines the extent of bud cold
hardiness as much as the genotype does
and here you can see I drew the dashed
red line to indicate the hardiest point
for ripe area and you can see that in
the first year the hardiest point is
sensitive relative in the next two years
the point of this being is buds do not
super cool to maximum potential unless
they have to unless they're pushed to do
it
so there has to be some sort of active
part of this going on here are the other
points for ripe area so you can just see
that it gradually got more and more
hardy across the three years assessing
quote our bud cold hardiness using LTE
is location and here dependent so this
makes it really hard to use to track
down genetic traits because it's always
changing with the field but I'm still
tasked with figuring out how to breed
for this so what's a genetic
architecture of this trait and can we
breed for it to do that I looked at
Vitus ripe area so this is that northern
North American very adapted cold hardy
wild species you can see here it has a
huge distribution and it goes well into
Canada that we just don't track where it
is in Canada so I looked at 43 different
varieties of ripe area and I'm gonna go
sort of fast through this part just show
you the variation across those 43
different individuals so here's 2013
2014 coal deer and these are the LTE's
for the different ripe areas would you
begin to notice is that they don't all
follow the same pattern so they're not
all responding to temperature the same
way you've got some that are sensitive
some that are Hardy some that are
reactive some that are static let's
cross the whole year or the whole winter
and here's the most recent winter and
you have the same sort of trend so even
when everybody's pushed as hard as we
can push them you still get a massive
amount of variation it's the end of this
okay so basically at any point in either
one of the winters there's ten degrees
Celsius range of variation so we have a
lot of stuff that we can look at for
breeding material and there's great
potential for incorporating some of this
new material into breeding programs that
include ripe area for for grape vine
breeding the interesting thing is
northern varieties did not come out as
always the most Hardy so in the first
year here varieties that were harder
than negative 32 degrees Celsius were
from Montreal Montana Ontario and
Illinois Illinois is considered south in
this distribution and in last year we
again had lots of northern material but
also Illinois Kansas Nebraska Iowa and
Texas it was really interesting this
trait does not appear to be tied to
geography it seems to be locked within
the species okay so now we're gonna move
to the next straight dormancy dormancy
is a process that occurs throughout the
growing season and throughout the
dormant season it starts during the
growing season with para dormancy this
is where the tip the growing tip is
suppressing the growth of buds behind it
so this is what happens when you prune a
plant and it gets really bushy you
release it from pair dormancy that's
controlled by hormones the next type of
dormancy is endo dormancy and this is
what occurs in the fall light changes
cold temperatures drop and the Canes and
fruit or canes and vines ripen off so
they turn from green to brown getting
woody that's called paradigm it advances
from the base of the cane to the
the cane and as it travels the buds that
are covered in that paradigm are ready
for winter we don't know what keeps
these buds in this state of endo
dormancy it's something molecular
metabolic if you go out during the endo
dormant period and hack off a vine stick
it in water and try to get the buds grow
it won't burst there's something limit
keeping those buds silent after you
successfully complete endo dormancy you
move on eco dormancy and this is the
state where the temperatures are keeping
the plant dormant so if you go and cut a
vine an eco dormant stage and put it in
a hot glass of water it'll grow so this
is an environmental form of dormancy
after it gets warm enough and growth
through zooms the plant goes back into
the girls season but if it gets there
too fast and we have a frost event then
this happens and we lose the fruit
producing parts of the vine so that's
why this is related to cold hardiness
the way the dormancy clock works is the
buds somehow keep track of the amount of
time that they spend between about 7 or
0 degrees Celsius and 7 degrees Celsius
there's an optimum area there they count
the hours throughout the whole winter
and that's what's depicted here the two
winters 2012 and 2013 so warm versus
cold in this green shading is that sweet
spot for that dormancy o'clock so the
buds are tracking temperatures
throughout the winter and this tells
them when it's safe to burst in the
spring so I zoomed in here just in the
yellow box on the same dates across
those two years the warm winter and the
cool winter and if we imagine that we
want to get to 12 o'clock noon before we
burst and look at this region you can
see that in the warm winter they made it
to 7 o'clock in this chunk of time in
the next year when it was cold they only
made it to 3 what that means is you need
much less warmth on the other side of
this this bracketed area to burst and in
fact in this year you can see that
they've got plenty of chilling the buds
burst and we got frost damage
and this year this same amount of
chilling didn't mean the same amount to
the buds because the clock was slower so
it's really important that you grow
things in regions that have C o'clock up
12 that you don't grow things that are
going to be super charged in that time
this is what the the chilling hour /
dormancy cloth looks like for across the
country
if the I'm not sure if you can read
these these numbers or not but it starts
with zero in Florida it never gets below
seven so plants that would grow in
Florida wouldn't need chilling in order
to fulfill their dormancy you gradually
gain more dormancy as you move up the
country along the coast where it's cool
up in a Pacific Northwest where it's
cool and then up in the northern plains
there's actually very few chilling hours
this is because their temperature swings
are so dramatic they go through from
summer to winter so quickly that that
sweet zone is actually very tiny so
that's chilling hours and we can
evaluate what the chilling hour
requirement is for different species for
different genotypes by simple tests
collecting the vines putting them into
cold storage in that sweet spot and then
testing how fast they burst and the data
looks something like this this is
Cabernet Franc at Sauve and Riesling at
the start of experiment you can see that
they take quite a few days to burst but
as you add chilling they get faster and
faster and faster if you take a given
set of hours at a thousand hours here
you can see that Cab Franc and Riesling
our fully chilled and they're bursting
really quickly and caps off is lady
legging behind one of the consequences
of not being fully chilled is that you
have desynchronized budburst that leads
to D synchronized flowering and D
synchronized fruit ripening so this is
not a good trait to have you can see
here this is Riesling that's fully
chilled this is caps off that's not
fully chilled the buds are bursting at
different rates
so if we look across a wild grapevine
these are the trends in what the species
do when we're faced with chilling hours
I want you to notice that all the
species responded the same way too
chillin there they all need chilling to
burst but they and they have the same
reaction to the same amount of chilling
but they start at different spots in the
y-intercept and so different species and
genotypes have different chilling
requirements there's low chilled rapid
bud bursting species moderate species
and then hide she'll slow species these
tend to separate along a northern
southern gradient as far as
distributions go so it's very
interesting we might have an adaptive
trait in this data set so we can select
specific germ plasm to breed for these
different traits so if we will look at
this in ripe area again we could look at
this with 43 lines I'm not going to show
you 43 lines I'm just going to show you
a standard ripe area line so this is
ripe areas response to increasing
chilling it gets faster and faster for
the bud burst so chilling hours in the
are going up here bud burst days on the
left this is the maximal range of
variation within the forty-three ripe
areas okay so all of the right Perea
lines fall between this blue and this
green line what we see is that the
steeper the slope is that indicates that
that genotype reef responds more to a
given unit of chilling and the position
on the y axis indicates the end of
dormancy barrier so the higher you are
on the y axis the more dormant you are
through the winter if we look at if we
imagine we breed with these ripe areas
and then put the hybrids out into North
America where we're growing hybrid
grapes pictured here is North Dakota
Nebraska New York and a chilling hours
that you typically receive in those
regions so you can see depending up if
you planted the for example the green
variety in all three locations you have
very different bud burst rates because
they're chilling hours and seasons are
different if you add adapting or climate
change and winter warming to this you
shift these all to the side and so when
you're thinking about breeding for cold
hardiness from a dormancy point of view
you have to be think
way ahead to the shift in climate
there's increase in chilling hours and
so now you can see is even more
important which varieties you choose
because the faster you break bud the
more susceptible to frost you are and
this is the 43 different genotypes of
ripe area yellow is southern I've called
them southern blue is northern in the
two columns is the average LTE for the
two years I showed you you can see that
there is no apparent trend between
darker red with northern or southern the
LTE trade is sort of shared across all
of those individuals if you then include
the dormancy information as slope and
y-intercept so here's the what slope and
y-intercept means
lure and slope means you will react
stronger to the chilling blue and the
y-intercept means you have a higher end
of dormancy
you can see there seems to be a possible
association between the southern having
higher ended endodermis e and a higher
response and chilling and the north
there's more red so you tend to be have
lower end o dormancy and so there's
several potential varieties if you look
across these traits that might be good
for breeding so we'd want red in the
slope blue in the y-intercept and then
also Hardy in the LTE and so I've
highlighted a few of them here and you
can see this is from Missouri Illinois
Iowa Kansas Montana and Ontario you can
see that you have the option to breed
with far more material if you consider
southern ripe area in a grapevine
breeding program okay
so now we're gonna do a quick shift up
so this is the phenotyping effort that
I've been leading in Geneva trying to
figure out these traits trying to figure
out how much of it we can use in
Grapevine breeding there's only so much
you can do in the field because as I
showed you every winter changes and it
gets very frustrating to try to run a
controlled experiment when the outside
keeps changing on you so what we do is
we take the field research to the lab
and we can take hints from the field
research so we know that all the species
reacted the same to chilling increasing
both our bud burst rate and their
synchronicity
the end of dormancy and LTE trade seem
to be a little bit tied to one another
but maybe that's only by chance and
there's variation within ripe area
suggesting that endo dormancy may be
adaptive and LTE may be a species static
trait so then I would want to know can
we determine the mechanism behind these
traits and so this is I'm gonna
introduce my student al Kowalewski we is
working with me and we're working on
trying to dissect D acclamation so we
want to look for the correlation of D
acclamation phenotype and budburst
phenotype so what we did is we took by
de samme rensis by de stripe area those
are those Clarke cold hardy wild species
and Vitis vinifera and we subjected them
to a test and so here are some of the
stats on the species amiran sis and ripe
area are fast FD kilometers limited
chilling hours and fast bud bursting
species in vinifera we have slower d
acclamation slower bud burst and if you
look at Riesling and Cabernet Sauvignon
you'll see that there's a pretty big
difference there in the chilling hours
so we can compare the normal bud burst
rate with a delayed bud burst rate and
what we do is we take a whole bunch of
canes from the field
put them into growing conditions where
everything is controlled and sampled the
material for Bud hardiness check it for
bud burst phenology and then look at
gene expression so here's an example of
what the experiment looks like on day 10
if you can see hopefully you can see
that you can see a Muir ences has greens
full and bud
buds so I mentioned it's the fastest bud
breaker if you look at ripe area
Riesling our cap saw and you can find
the buds they're not breaking bud so
there's just an example of what our data
looks like as we're taking it we have
several hypotheses associated with the
gene expression when it comes to the
processes of D acclimation bud burst and
cold hardiness so based on the field
data we would think that the acclimation
genes would be on in all genotypes but
would be tied to the actual rate of D
acclimation for each species bud burst
genes should be all up regulated and
also tied to the rate of bud burst for
each species and that genes are that are
important for cold hardiness and cold
survival should be massively down
regulated because there is no longer a
stress
so what we did is we did hunt we
collected hundreds of cuttings on
February 2nd and here's the chilling
hours at in the field at on February 7th
it's about 750 hours and what that means
is that my rents this riparian Riesling
are all fully chilled caps top is not
here's their their field D acclamation
response this is from LT so we know that
riparian amaranthus are fast reasoning
in cab stop are slow and they're
budburst phenology in this experiment
reflected their chilling hours so we had
a Muir ences first ripe area second
Riesling third and Cabernet started
bursting about the same time as Riesling
but I was really stretched out because
it was not fully chilled so not
synchronized this data is showing you
the D acclamation rate 22 degrees for
ripe area and a Muir Ensis so these data
points are the cold hardiness levels
measured by LTE each day and then here
and these dashed lines is the
temperature of some control canes we
left in the cold room at 4:00 so treat
is exactly the same but kept at 4
degrees instead of 22 if we look at
cultivated grape here's the D
acclamation rates at 22 C and at 4 C the
first thing you'll notice is that the
rate of D acclamation of eco dormant
buds is exactly the same the slope is
not different amongst these four
varieties so this is totally in contrast
to what we see in the field what we
think is this happened because we put
them into 22 degrees Celsius 24 hours a
day which is not a realistic situation
this is the problem with going from the
field to the lab sometimes you can
overshoot so we basically put them in a
maximum growth rate
condition and they all D acclimated the
same however at 4 degrees C you see that
only a mere Ensis was deactivating at a
different rate so this means that that
species has is able to respond to much
cooler temperatures and this would make
sense from a field point of view because
it D acclimates the fastest in the field
as well and you spend much more time at
4 than you do at 22 so in this
experiment we've decoupled D acclimation
in budburst
so we can't look at gene expression
patterns in the same way that we were
planning but we can still look at what
was going on so here are day 0 through
d8 this is the D acclamation rate these
are the days that we sampled for RNA
seek genes that have shared expression
that are important for D acclimation are
going to be about the same for all four
varieties because they're all d
acclimating at the same rate genes that
have a staggered expression pattern are
going to be tied to budburst because
they're bud bursting at different rates
and genes that go down are related to
cold hard ass these are assumptions so
what we did is we collected material on
each of these days for the entire
experiment round them up and did
extractions for RNA and then sequence
that RNA and i'm not sure how many
people are done RNA seekin here but
basically we sequenced over almost 1
billion RNA sequencing reads it was an
enormous data set after we cleaned it up
we have about 500,000 reads in this
experiment if you take those 500,000
reads and align them to the genome and
try to figure out which genes are turned
on which genes are turned off we out of
the 32,000 predicted cultivated grape
genes we picked up about 13 to 16,000 so
you go from almost a billion points of
data to hopefully just 13 to 16 thousand
which is still a massive data set if you
then apply some statistics and look at
significantly differentially expressed
genes we can cut that data set way down
to the max 4,000 genes invited Samuel
rinses are on or off in this experiment
and in right area just under 2,000 so
it's still a massive data set to deal
with but this is how we're going about
looking at it if you're unfamiliar with
micro chip analysis or rna-seq analysis
this is what a heat map of RNA seek data
looks like blue to red indicates down to
up gene regulation so blue genes are
down regulated red genes are upregulated
and what you can see here in this
cluster and this cluster is that the
genes start out down regulated and
gradually increase in gene expression
and the difference between these two is
this one I guess you could say it's
gradually up regulated whereas this is
early up regulated you see the
transition from blue to red is faster in
this box and this box are down regulated
genes so they start high and they end
low and then in this little box here you
can see they start blue go red go back
to blue so these are genes that are
coming on probably starting a signal
cascade and then being shut off so those
are peaking genes so again these are our
gene numbers we have this is a Muir and
since I'm showing you so this is the
3923 genes each line isn't in is a gene
if we look at up regulated genes that
are found in all four of our different
genotypes
there's only 447 genes so this is this
is much more manageable than even 3,000
genes if we look at genes that are
shared in the down-regulation category
there's roughly 230 across all four
varieties so now we can look at these
genes and see what sort of differences
in gene expression are going on in all
of these processes so I picked some just
at random this this is not I didn't
choose this because there's a tada
moment coming or anything like that I
just wanted to show you some of the gene
expression patterns and some of the
processes that were identifying or that
are related to in this case D
acclimation so as I mentioned D
acclimation occurred equally among all
four varieties so we'd expect you an
expression to be more or less all up for
everybody and you can see some of that
here gibberellin 3 beta hydroxylase ox 1
these are things were related to
hormones
JoEllen and oxen ABC transporters lipid
transporter proteins if I'm not sure if
you can see the y-axis here but it goes
from something like 2000 to around
18,000 expression units so massively up
regulated lipid transfer proteins
histone deacetylase is important for
actually shutting genes off it ties up
the DNA into histones and so this is
interesting that they're up regulated
and then cue pin here which is Cubans
have been seen to play a role in
germination and wheat so a lot of this
makes sense
in Inadi acclimation process and then
process
it's the butt is getting ready for
growth and a picture over here is some a
summary gibberellins auxins lipids like
we said I'm sorry the colors of the
lines here are indicated by the
genotypes in the same color but if you
want an easy easy key
blue and green or wild orange and purple
are cultivated so genes involved in
budburst we would hypotheses hypothesize
that these would be turned on fastest in
Douma rensis because it bursts fastest
followed by ripe area and then the
vanilla is and you can kind of see from
this that we were actually need to
extend our experiment beyond day because
we're not picking up a lot of that
cultivated response but here are six
genes that are upregulated rapidly and
we think would be playing a role as
budburst at ESO one is a floral organ
differentiating gene so this makes sense
the floral meristem is probably becoming
activated GSA forwards has a role in
gibberellin ethylene has a role alpha
tubulin and alpha extension these are
both expansion and an elongation type
genes and oxygen response factors so a
lot of growth things we look at down
regulated genes here's another sample of
just six this Plex string e or pH domain
protein that's the only information we
have on it but it goes from something
like 14,000 down to 2,000 so massively
down regulated this has a role in
membrane transports SRC 2 it's been
picked up in soybeans in response to
cold work regulation so this makes sense
another good candidate DREV genes and
were key genes are both transcription
factors that play a role in cold
hardiness dehydration stress even some
of the other stresses depending on the
family member Galactic Galacta null
synthase is plays a role in getting rid
of raffinose and raffinose is a sugar
that's been seen to be up regulated in
response to cold so this makes a lot of
sense it's being shut off as with any
gene expression study you get a whole
bunch of genes that have no function
attached to them unknown proteins or no
hit proteins and some of them have
really cool gene expression patterns so
here on the top are two that are down
regulated quite a bit two in the bottom
are up regulated so these are genes that
we we don't know what they do but they
they clearly play a role in this process
they're picked up and
all of our samples and then there's a
whole category stuff that just has weird
gene expression patterns and we can't
make a lot of sense of so there you have
to take it all with a little bit of salt
I've shown you a little bit out of that
450 and 230 but what we're doing is
trying to figure out candidate genes and
pathways that play a role in these
processes and so that's the ultimate
goal can we identify pathways that are
over represented within this data set so
we could then say the D acclimation
pathway is this and this is what you get
to work with if you're looking for doing
pathway analysis and which is why I'm
not going to show you today because I
can't do this but this is the metabolic
pathway and great for everything it's
not just cold response or anything so
instead I did one pathway I zeroed in on
because a lot of the candidate genes I
saw in the dataset
we're picking up in my memory about
flavonoid biosynthesis when I was a grad
student ID to do my preliminary
examination I had to write a grant on
flavonoid biosynthesis so I finally paid
off
and so I I saw that there's lots of
these genes I recognized and so I
thought I'd reek remake the pathway just
to see what was going on and so here's
the pathway that leads from
phenylalanine to flavonoids or to Mono
Lake Knowles and they all go through
this sort of intermediate which is
really important so if you go to the
left of this you turn into a flavonoid
if you go to the right you turn into a
lignin these are the genes and it's
really not important that you know what
their names are but maybe you know
chalcone synthase I think that plays a
lot of role and flower color and that
kind of stuff and so this pathway would
lead to color and Epis islands this is
peroxidase just in case you're
interested so basically we have
flavonoids or mono lignins
these are the genes in that pathway I
picked up almost every single gene
differentially expressed in all four
genotypes in this pathway but you can
see that it's not always the same so
shared expression down shared expression
down am your incest and ripe area are
starting to pick up pretty much shared
expression across the lignans but when
you get to the flavonoids em your
ancestors way up and right Perrier's ray
up so this suggests that maybe in
riparian Amir insists the flavonoid
pathway is playing a bigger role in
those buds ready for budburst orgy
acclimation something even though you
see all the genes are up here the
expression level of this isoform is much
lower than this one so it just gives us
an idea of what might be going on and so
here's that whole pathway pink is down
regulated green is up regulated and dark
green is massively up regulated so you
can kind of get an idea of maybe some of
the pathway that's playing a role in
this and my hope would be to take all of
the genes not just a few that I showed
you but apply that to some pathway
analysis and then determine if there are
other aspects of the metabolism that are
unique to different species are unique
to perhaps the difference between cab
solve and Riesling so again you sort of
like a buzz through physiology and
phenotyping and next-gen analysis and we
have got a lot of future plans with this
sort of research we want to look at more
controlled freezing experiments where we
take all the Canes into the into the
cooler in the beginning of the season
and subject them to freezing and warming
in a controlled manner so we can sort of
see their response to temperature better
we want to look at both endo dormant and
eco dormant D acclimation what what we
looked at today with eco dormant we also
want to do some diurnal sampling so and
Al's not particularly happy with this
but we're gonna go out in the field
we're gonna be sampling like every four
hours over several days to try to get
how the genes are being turned on and
off as that they warm up during the day
and then cold at night try to get a
better handle on how much gene
expression actually occurs near zero
ultimately we'd like to move this to
Association transcriptomics and look
within mapping populations to try to
find eqtl associated with dormancy
associated with the acclimation and one
area that's massively under studied is
cold hardiness in trunks and canes
that's something we haven't touched it
all here and it's not something that
I've done much work in but ultimately
we'd like to move into that area to try
to get whole vine responds so with that
I would just say thank you to the people
at USDA who support this work my
technician is Kathleen Dee's and a
previous technician jacqueline willis as
well as a farm crew bill John Bob Greg
and Nancy at Cornell of course my
student alcohol
skee he's been helping out a ton and is
going to be helping out a lot more
Bruce rice is his co advisor and Tim
Martinson and his team bill will Z Steve
loose Beth Takas and Lynn Johnson is
with the Cornell statistics group she
helps me out a lot and then I've got
some other collaborators on here oh you
can't even see that things in the way
and Fennell Dan [ __ ] wood Mitch Michaela
centenary and grant Cramer these people
all play a role in these same sorts of
phenotypes and so we all kind of work
together and I will just ask if there's
any questions I'd do my best to answer
them Thanks
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu